you hey hey Doc
hey Doc hey Doc hey Doc hey Doc hey Doc
Marty I'm sorry doc it's good to see you
Marty what's the matter doc don't worry
my only doing docking much money I don't
get it doc what barb on it doc what do
you mean will you be back
English doc your kids Marty wait a
minute doc wait a minute doc wait a
minute talk wait a minute doc here you
go Marty Marty it's perfect
try and Marty Jesus Christ doctor oh
this is heavy touch this is heavy duty
doctor you're the doc doc hey you're the
doc doc you're the doc doc Martin I
can't buddy up here doc doc doc doc
Marty
doc guy Marty Marty Marty Marty Marty
Marty hi doc doc doc doc doc doc doc doc
Marty Marty Marty doc hey Doc Marty
Marty Marty Marty Marty Marty please
take off your shirt doc doc doc doc
three three
doc doc look at your sweatshirt doc you
look great doc I gotta check this out
doc doc you gotta believe me
damn it doc what are you doing doc no
wait doc no no doc hey Doc you better
back up there is doc oh uh this is my
doc yo uncle dark it's from the doc doc
check it out doc this is Marty do you
read me over Chuck Marty doc document uh
Marty let's report that Marty Marty come
in doc party doc doc to me
what document money come in Barney
what's up doc doc great Marty doc party
shot funny
doc stop boy oh my god look at this you
clown it'll echo from did I adequately
answer your condescending question